sugli occhi venuti solita stories a
grandissima richiesta oggi nuovi giochi
palla e poi alla fine del video potete
scriverci quale è stato il vostro
preferito anche noi vi diremo il nostro
preferito è anche il più pauroso
cercherebbe a ogni giorno di giocare
suoi occhi paurosi perché adorato di
così poco e anche reati mangiavo pauroso
in cui giocavamo a fare i baby sitter e
con la mi chiamo nipote di grendi che va
dalla super paura mi è piaciuto
tantissimo quindi eccoci qua con altri
gioco e mi raccomando è stato un bel mi
piace o verrete perseguitati da uno di
questi prossimi aiuto che paura non mi
seguite il 30 grava data seguirmi il
nome mita stories se volesse ritmi anche
se tic tac
mettetevi comodi prenditi pop corn e
iniziamo subito primo gioco il primo
gioco pauroso a cui giocheremo e piccoli
brividi a notte della paura super bello
anche per come vedete appaiono vari
mostri 15 ci sono vari molti la p e se
ci seguite da un po sapete benissimo che
la p iniziamo subito scritto guarda le
impronte per muoverti ecco vedi ci sono
le c'è qualcuno che sta parlando ha
detto pieni verso di me non c'è molto
tempo si avvicina disse di cliccare la
macchina da scrivere
e allora il paraguay nella macchina da
scrivere che sto parlando
qualcuno ad avere il blocco dello
scrittore mi serve inchiostro prendi
l'inchiostro nel cassetto
ok prendiamo l'inchiostro nel cassetto
eccolo il cassetto
ci sarà bisogno nasconditi sotto la
scrivania erice ci sono chi sta
arrivando
guardate troppi lo vedete hanno fatto in
tempo a nascondermi racconta la
scrivania
devo tenere premuti tieni premuto ok
siamo nascosti trattando sta rubando dei
libri che paura dove i fan tardi ok
possa se ne sta andando così possiamo
uscire dalla scrivania si è uscito di
pista ci hai più accorto stabili
attraverso vanity le bande con il colle
ecco che ha detto che floppy deve essere
fermato subito quindi di prendere il
libro dalla statue tizia ok ok a volte
ha detto che era il libro mancano alcune
pagine con una paesino vicino al
caminetto
oppure che spuntino pure altri mostri ho
detto andiamo a ecco la pagina ha detto
che mancano ancora due pagine ma
dobbiamo accendere la luce per prendere
poi la chiave per uscire dallo studio
quindi dobbiamo trovare altre due pagine
per fermare slappy trovata la luce ha
detto che la chiave è nascosta dietro i
libri blu quindi qui immagino e spero
che si sta dietro
raccoglie i due pagine al piano di sopra
qualcosa mi dice che hai visto c'era
stabili dice non voglio store aumentarti
ma se vedi o senti qualcosa di strano
nasconditi c'è qualche mostro o c'è uno
zombie li interessa new york ok dice di
mantenere una certa distanza perché
comunque lenta e non è molto
intelligente questo zombie tempo
sì forse meglio nascondersi almeno è
lenta e così noi dobbiamo correre tra
venendo qui spero non ci abbia visto
anche nella tempesta o no dice che ci ha
visto nonostante sia tanto esempio lenta
non ci prendeva speriamo non so dove
siamo stati presi prima del flop ma
immagino che ci saranno tutti i mostri
dei libri quindi dobbiamo stare molto
attento lo in bagno non penso ci siano
nascondere dentro lo volte per ora non
so dove era già arrivata ma non mi
sembrava lo zombie sembrava qualcosa io
ero lo zombie zombie
guarda che cosa c'era uno ogni uomo
cattivo che ha rubato una pagina dove
andato rotto qualcosa
ecco la pagina guarda vediamo se riesco
prato che trasmette aspetto lo gnomo ce
lo zombie che sta passando
ok ok aspetta state è descritto aspetto
aspetto affabili nella porta bene che
fortuna che si è rotto lo gnomo si è
comunque bello e più mi piace a voi
piace questa mattina quando andiamo
treno corso vi nascondo che non c'è
nessuno
ecco la resa ai presso tutte le pagine
ora trova slap in trappola un bel libro
honda non ce la faremo mai pagare troppi
avvicinati a fra petrini tieni premuto
su di lui dice
[Musica]
il libro hai vinto bene io vi ho avuto
del capitolo un'ora capitolo 2 raccogli
nuove pagine per il libro al piano di
sotto che sarà il nuovo mostro da
intrappolato al piano di sotto e
restante qual è il problema pensavo che
saremmo diventati amici nostra è ancora
là fuori sta scappando ma è scappato in
cisnero compiti poi le guidances dice ma
ora dobbiamo farlo di nuovo e troverai
nuove pagine al piano di sotto c'è una
pagina qualcosa non l'ho visto qui sotto
allora nelle conditi nascondiamo la
prendiamo con i testi così facciamo
passare allo zombie prima
perché si è fermata qua e che non devo
tenere premuto perché se mi scappa il
dito io sto fuori
e quindi mi prende subito ok ok se n'è
andata siamo sopravvissuti a questo
nascondino allora prendiamo la pagina
bene uno di 61 al 35
dobbiamo prendere comunque somiglia
molto al film di piccoli brividi non so
se l'avete visto comunque tutti i mostri
dei libri escono fuori dai libri e
diventano così i reali e quindi ci sono
un gruppo di amici che devono assieme
allo scrittore che devono il re
intrappolarli dentro i profili perché
dobbiamo fare quando è nel videogioco
bellissimo dice che un animator 3000 se
fossi in te mi terrei lontano da quel
raggio a rosso è un tipo un robottino
provare a prenderlo forse ce ne
sarebbero raggio rosso
ecco vedete noi dobbiamo recuperare
quella pagina prima che passi il razzo
rosso può essere molto veloce questa
casa è molto paurosa vi piazze scappare
adesso briga briga di rischio non mi fa
passare non mi fa davanti sono scossa
pochissimo se anche il temporale fuori
che rende il tutto ancora più bello
tauro marinano ok allora questo abbiamo
preso ok vediamo se riusciamo a trovare
con un'altra pagina
io abbiamo preso un'altra pagina cela
mancano ancora tre e chicco se questo
rumor fuoco berlina fi correndo il
colore così perché ho sentito del
sellino visto qualcosa che si muoveva le
forze slap uno dice che in questa fase
in questa stanza ci sarà una o più
pagine ho paura che sia qualche mostro
nascondiamoci ok
sento il rumore della pagina lo senti
cosa dove dove non lo so tu hai visto
qualcosa mi sono pentito ma non capisco
che un mostro sia molto critica allora
dobbiamo controllare bene perché ha
detto che c'è uno più pagina qui si
proviamo a vedere così bravo
dobbiamo nasconderci ho sentito ho
sentito lo zombie
non riesco a vederlo tornando proprio
qua ma quante lenta allora lì c'erano i
cereali quindi lo può anche chiudere gli
occhi o non ci piace l'ho visto domenica
no non si può vedere qui sotto spero
guarda lo gnomo ok per lo meno male se
n'è andata comunque se qualcun altro
governa scorso qua perché sento un altro
verso una banana avremo tutti i cassetti
uffa dove saranno nascoste queste pagine
eccola sei bravo
queste pagine ci manca ancora dura sono
lusingata e rotolo il nuovo mercato
normativi di ceramica tipo non abbiamo
trovato l'altrapagina quindi continuiamo
ad esplorare la casa
in bagno siamo nascosti nella lavatrice
o comunque bello questo nascondino mauro
per fortuna non ci ha visto dentro la
nostra bravo
ok era nella camera da letto ora ne
mancano guarda penso se l'avevano rubata
ok troviamo la devi trovare un momento
splash i profeti dice di di assicurarsi
che le luci
eccone qualcuna della colonna dietro e
come faccio mai
devo accendere le luci li sa perché le
luci devono starci se non so cosa sono
sta scappando e visto sta scappando
[Musica]
motivi resto devo accendere le luci per
forza dobbiamo accendere le luci e
colori
eccole bravo a parlare a dove scatti che
sta facendo
non riesco a prenderlo per ora qui
sì siamo volta nonostante gli errori
della prima notte riuscì a ficcare
troppi nei limiti e questa volta per
sempre
ovvero uno strano odore nell'aria che
riportò a spa in qualcosa di diabolico
qualcosa alto circa un metro e il fatto
di legno la fee è ancora vivo io sono
ancora una macchina da scrivere e ancora
in casa mia è ancora qui grazie al cielo
quindi slappy è riuscito a scappare di
nuovo da lima nasconditi dice dice
piacere un altro mostro che si sente
pagine questa volta forse lupo mannaro
sì però diceva fatto di legno
guarda i padroncini
penso che se questo si prende chip a
brandelli ma siamo al prossimo gioco
vostro volete che continuiamo questo
gioco di piccoli brividi che è un
viaggio garantirvi lasciato un bel mi
piace scrivetecelo nei commenti che voto
gli diamo
beh io direi un 9 e mezzo è su problemi
che gli do un bel 9 perché mi piace st
foti deve catturare i mostri che ogni
volta sono mostri si sente che c'è una
casa paura sa se volete le continuiamo
nel canale di evitare quindi se state un
bel mi piace fatto sapere mico medievo
siamo al prossimo prossimo celato
pauroso come potete vedere anche qua c'è
una casa paurosa questo gioca si chiama
scary ciaio stato creato dai creatori di
schieriti 0
quello punto scary speri però questa
volta più pauroso di scaligeri in più
c'è un bambino malefico ci attacca
insomma vediamo come possiamo
eccolo questa scheri child allora dice
la casa è posseduta da un bambino
spaventoso sky inside prima di entrare
nella casa di ritrovarli ritrovare un
piede di porco è una scala per entrare
open
vediamo se riusciamo solo ok eccolo che
lo possiamo prendere già una bella
questa casa paurosa io adoro le case
paurose se non si fosse capito già da
un'altra volta che abbiamo giocato
spiriti sera halloween la porta
principale e chiuse ha bisogno di una
password segreta per essere aperta cerca
la password per entrare nella casa
oppure cerchiamo scritto qualcosa li 4
che abbiamo avviato il suggerimento dice
di guardare il numero della casa che un
12 che vediamo e ei ha funzionato
possiamo entrare dentro la casa con rosa
c'è una chiave dentro questa casa che
apre tutte le porte
devi trovarla andiamo a trovarla
[Musica]
ok allora si è scritto che questo che
sta indicando con la mano è un
indicatore di fantasmi e quando ces che
richard vicino quindi che riceve da un
fantasma aumenta insomma va bene allora
ho imparato che voi tenete d'occhio
l'indicatore di fantasmi a disse di
selezionare la scala che paura dice ok
abbiamo preso la chiave che però ci
dobbiamo fare meno male ancora non è
arrivato scheda ed allora dice di
entrare nel garage e rubare il
destructor fatti e ti aiuterà ad
affrontare sky child dice che la porta
del garage ea destra
al lato della porta con la chiave è che
praticamente festa di destructor ci sarà
questa mostra il cuscino dove scorregge
ruby come se anche sarebbe lì che si ha
fame di padre scorretto ma come facciamo
distrarre che si no allora dobbiamo
trovare il libro delle milanesi che
usera a rompere l'incantesimo su sky
child quindi ora sappiamo che riceve un
fantasma sta cercando la sua mamma ea un
incantesimo forse un bambino normale che
è stato incantato è stato trasformato in
quanto per piano non capisco perché
piano ha già preso ok ricominciamo non
ha idea di quante vite abbiamo non so se
sia come granny che cinque giorni quindi
cinque vite di tante somma non riesco a
capire dove siamo
allora di quasi esce fuori qui vicino
vicino mandolino scorre vicino
ok riproviamo
ho trovato una busta
margherita vicino alla piscina anche
nella piscina con tasto ok abbiamo
l'ultima volta a trovare questo libro di
incantesimi
si può non avanti prossimo gioco ce la
mette richiesto in tanti steaua bisogno
di scrivere giocare ad hainan
2 perché è uscito il 2 giu abbiamo
giocato l'anno scorso a devil you know
my super pauroso e quindi prepariamoci
vediamo cosa ci aspetta in queste due
come sempre penso che dovremmo scappare
dalla scuola vediamo che iniziamo in
modalità fantasma così forse riusciamo a
fare qualcosa altrimenti si prendono
stati ci vediamo qualcuno sta suonando
al pianoforte
non so forse sta parlando la sua
infanzia può essere se qualche segreto
nella sua infanzia
[Musica]
comunque notare che già in quel
calderone bruciandolo foto perché lei o
ed affini o e la mamma nella foto
[Musica]
sentire devi fuggire da questa scuola
okay campo bisogna sempre fuggire qua
c'è una bambola strana qua ci sono dei
mostri strani questi sono delle uova si
serve la spara uova e dove andiamo
persone che speriamo è chiusa quindi
sarebbe stato troppo facile riuscire a
scappare subito non puoi proseguire
pericoloso perché senso giunta non hai
uno come un bravo tipo ma non ci fa
perdere dobbiamo trovare la via d'uscita
tra l'altro ho vissuto i quai nell'henan
due c'è anche ice cream via iscrive
tornate sarà quando e perché sapete che
i creatori di hainan sono gli stessi
creatori di ice cream e gli stessi
creatori di mister ministro peraltro non
penso che saremo abbastanza bravi da
riuscire ad arrivare a incontrare scream
oratino c'è qualcosa qua c'è scritto
entra nel corridoio
abbiamo scoperto un passaggio anche
grande abbiamo spostato il tappeto e
adesso si può scendere giù un altro
passaggio le prigioni non sei abbastanza
forte per aprirti un parco quando c'è
qualcosa una leva paura di cosa vestirà
da lì a scegliere questo tunnel per
iniziare il capitolo esperimento chimico
vediamo cosa c'è sul tavolo prima pezzo
li arma ok abbiamo quindi questo forse
lo possiamo mettere qui no cosa è meglio
esperimento chimico questa è guerra e
non svegliare il resto chimico ok
vediamo cosa ci aspetta
i polli sono pericolosi addormentano
anche bello essere fuori da quella
scuola
servono a chiave la batterie collegate
ai cavi forse bisogna tagliare i cavi
non puoi fare nulla con la mano sia
qualcosa noi non ci facciamo male con le
cesoie s'è fatto quello bertaglia ricavi
si no mi sono accorto
meno male che modalità ok ok vediamo
come el altra missione airport ancora
più difficile sarà o no siamo finiti
tipo nella si chiama tour tipo l'aria
condizionata
sarà un labirinto questo una botola e
tutto il labirinto non c'erano mappa
questo eternit trappole abbiamo ma suona
troppo
ok ci siamo persi labirinto
abbiamo ricominciato questa volta però
non siamo più modalità fantasma secondo
voi quanto riuscivano a sopravvivere
secondo me
la dormendo poco a chi non si è
sbagliato ma perché loro possono
prendere il regista di sia anche loro a
pallone difficilissimo perché se questo
punto che il turchino di ho preso già
game over all huh perdonare troppo
difficile questo gioco ma provi a
giocare a varese voi sentite riusciti
ciò che mi piace un sacco questo già
quando sta in modo pauroso
però noi non riusciamo bene a giocare il
mio preferito è stato il primo quello di
piccoli brividi
rossi era super carino c'era una bella
storia dietro ci si poteva muovere
nascondere la sua si è il vostro
preferito da estate scrivetecelo nei
commenti ora mi lasciavo ancora 4 casa e
menez come cliccare per vedere inoltre
altri video al caso su quella che
preferite
buona visione